this is so important for us in the
pacific northwest but it's also
important throughout the south and for
our many many coastal communities so
this transportation legislation that
went through the commerce committee as i
said also um
you know it makes other investments uh
this floor bill also makes other
investments
for bridge repair for transit systems
for climate resiliency and specifically
for our airports probably haven't heard
too much about that out here on the
floor but in the commerce committee i
can tell you that aviation
transportation and competitive i know
the the presiding the president knows
this very well that in las vegas or in
reno that infrastructure like our
airports is essential to our economy is
continuing to grow
seatac is probably one of the fastest
growing airports in the united states
right now
and under this legislation we will also
see an important improvement for our
airports so they can continue to grow so
we can continue to make investments
i also want to as i mentioned thank
senator wicker
in the title for vehicle safety these
are important provisions that he and i
and others on the committee senator
blumenthal for his work on
safety legislation that
related to both the northeast corridor
and to individuals
in in transportation
including
with senator wicker the life-saving
technology that automatic like automatic
emergency braking system and preventing
child heat stroke deaths in impaired
driving facilities so madam president i
again thank the members of the commerce
city for their hard work in getting this
legislation as part of this package i
think we can see that uh we have some
firsts here first investing mega
projects first cleaning up our
environmental problems with culverts
getting our freight product through our
most congested quarters with improved
upgrade crossing and making the major
investment that amtrak can continue to
expand so i look forward working with my
colleagues as we move through
the legislative process and continue to
make improvements in our transportation
infrastructure i thank the president i
yield the floor
republican leader
later today senate democrats
want to take their next big step
toward playing russian roulette with our
country
they want to begin pushing through a
reckless taxing and spending spree
that was authored by our self-described
socialist colleague
chairman sanders
today the american people will learn
exactly where each of their senators
stand
the american people elected
a 50-50 senate an incredibly close
house of representatives and a president
who pledge
to govern down the middle and unify the
country
but as soon as president biden speaker
pelosi and leader schumer got the keys
they handed them right over to the far
left
remember democrats inherited three state
and effective vaccines that were already
rolling out nationwide
and an economy that was primed to come
roaring back
but our colleagues pressed ahead with a
massive springtime spending package that
even liberal experts said
would drive inflation
and of course it did
overall inflation has risen at the
fastest rate and nearly 13 years
core inflation hit its highest level
in almost 30 years
families are getting hit by higher
prices everywhere from the grocery store
to the gas station
to their housing costs
small businesses have had trouble
reopening because would-be workers are
getting a government bonus to actually
stay home
so the country is still working through
the side effects
of the borrowing and spending the
democrats forced through
back in the spring
but democrats don't want to just refill
their socialist prescription
they want to double the dose
double the dose
according to what they just released
democrats want to unite behind chairman
sanders resolution
to spend a staggering 4.2 trillion more
dollars
of course outside experts estimate the
real cost
will be even higher still
if it's even close to fully offset
as they claim it is this seems almost
certain to be the largest peacetime tax
hike on record
so let that sink in the largest
peacetime tax hike
on record
even though they're rough sketch of
these tax hikes would shatter president
biden's promise not to raise taxes
on the middle class
families earning well under the present
stated threshold
would get hit and hit hard
this new reckless taxing and spending
spree will fall like a hammer blow on
workers and middle-class families
fewer jobs
lower wages
more inflation pushing costs higher and
higher
what our colleagues are proposing and
planning is absolutely jaw-dropping
people want to pretend this is just
business as usual
just liberals doing liberal things using
senate procedure
make no mistake
this reckless taxing and spending spree
is nothing
like we've seen nothing
the basic math of their taxing and
spending is toxic enough
but the radicalism that will be that
we'll be debating
on the floor
goes well beyond
dollars and cents
the policies they want to put behind
this budget resolution read like
somebody walked across the rotunda to
the house
and handed the squad
a pen and piece of paper
sweeping
sweeping amnesty for illegal immigrants
in the middle of the border crisis
regulations that are so radical that our
colleague senator markey quote
said the green new deal is in the dna of
this budget resolution
all of the things that are in this we
talked about in the green new deal end
quote senator markey
they want to introduce 49 other states
to make their
they want to induce 49 other states to
make their electric grids
more like california's
make it more expensive to mine critical
minerals we need to compete with china
they want to make to take working
families child tax credit and turn it
into a permanent welfare program listen
to this
with no work requirement
they want to tamper with the
prescription drug industry in ways that
would leave americans with fewer new
treatments
and fewer new cures
they want to put government's thumb on
the scale of families child care choices
and selectively subsidize parents whose
households
work the way washington wants
and they want to tax more money out of
americans pockets
while reviving a special tax cut that
overwhelmingly benefits wealthy people
in blue states
so let's face it
the brute facts of the senate's rules
mean that if 50 democrats plus the vice
president stick together
republicans will probably not be able to
save our colleagues from themselves
if all 50 democrats want to help
chairman sanders hurt middle-class
families
if even our colleagues who claim their
moderates want to follow the far left
off this clip
well
that's their prerogative
but we're going to argue it out right
here on the floor
at some length
every single center will be going on
record
over
and over
and over
senate republicans will be bringing
forward commonsense amendments that
represent what americans actually want
and actually need
our colleagues can look forward to votes
on national security and funding our
armed forces
votes to remove backdoor tax cuts for
wealthy liberals
votes to protect family owned small
businesses and family farms from
crushing [ __ ] hikes
votes to encourage schools to finally
reopen
in person
to stop the catch and release of covert
positive illegal immigrants coming in to
our country
to protect taxpayers from being forced
to fund the horrors of abortion
and that's just a sampling
because our democratic colleagues missed
some deadlines
it has been an all-out sprint to prepare
amendments
so i want to thank our non-partisan
senate clerks and parliamentarians
they work multiple weekends straight
through
they were kept up late last night
processing hundreds of amendments
and they're going to be up late with all
of us
yet again
if president biden and 50 senate
democrats want to outsource domestic
policy to chairman sanders if this is if
this historically reckless taxing and
spending spree is how the modern
democratic party wants to define itself
if they want inflation and tax hikes to
be their legacy
then republicans do not currently have
the votes to spare the american families
this nightmare
but
we will debate
and we will vote
and we will stand up
and we will be counted
and the people of this country will know
exactly which senators fought for them
[Music]
i suggest
the clerk will call the role
ms baldwin
[Music]
you
[Music]
um
[Music]
this
[Music]
mr president
the majority whip is recognized are we
in the quorum call
we are asking him is consent the quorum
call be suspended without objection
mr president this past saturday
at 9 00 pm
chicago police officer ella french
was shot and killed
during a traffic stop on the chicago
south side
her death is
devastating officer french was 29 years
old
she'd served as a member of the chicago
police department since 2018.
her brother described her
as the epitome of a good samaritan
a fellow officer said of her and i quote
she truly showed the community that she
loved them
and would do anything for them
officer french's partner was also shot
and critically wounded
we pray for his recovery
two men have been charged by the cook
county state's attorney's office in the
shooting of these officers
the third man has been charged by the
u.s attorney's office for the northern
district of illinois
for conspiracy to violate federal
firearms laws
i hope that justice is delivered swiftly
and fairly for the perpetrators of this
horrible crime
and let me be clear as devastating as
her death
scores of individuals are shot every
week in chicago and many lose their
lives
for each of their families the loss is
just as intense as the loss of officer
french
and as heartbreaking as officer
frenchness death is
it is also infuriating
we learned yesterday from the chicago
u.s attorney's office that the gun used
to murder officer french
was straw purchased from a gun dealer in
indiana
what is a straw purchase
it happens when a person who can pass a
background check
buys a gun and gives it to a person who
can't
straw purchases have
long been the way that guns have
funneled into the hands of those with
felony convictions in chicago
than to the streets
than to deadly incidents
according to the charges filed yesterday
by the u.s attorney an indiana man
bought the handgun from a dealer in
hammond indiana
gave it to a person with a felony
conviction
who allegedly used it this last weekend
to kill officer french
for years i have been fighting to
toughen our laws against straw purchases
right now straw purchasing is treated
listen to this as a federal paperwork
violation
for lying on a federal gun purchase form
charges are rarely brought
and when they are the sentences are
often just a matter of months
that needs to change
i've joined with senator leahy of
vermont senator collins of maine to
introduce the stop illegal trafficking
and firearms act a bipartisan bill that
would make an explicit federal crime
carrying felony penalties when a person
straw purchase a firearm
we need to take this type of gun
trafficking seriously
it's time for us to stop treating straw
purchases like a paperwork misdemeanor
as we have learned in the death of
officer french it is a deadly act and
should be punished accordingly
officer french's death is also a call to
action for the strike force
recently set up by the department of
justice to crack down
on regional firearms trafficking in
chicago
i met with attorney general garland in
chicago when he launched the strike
force two weeks ago and i have written
to him
now
urging that the strike force immediately
prioritized the investigation
prosecution of straw purchases like the
one that took the life of officer french
the strike force was established to keep
a sustained focus
on firearms trafficking in chicago
that focus should include
stopping straw purchases
and holding the perpetrators
accountable i look forward to working
with the justice department and with my
colleagues to find ways to crack down
on the deadly gun violence that straw
purchasers help to feel
fuel
mr president i ask for
consent that the next statement may
be placed at a separate part in the
record
without objection
mr president 2020 set a record for drug
overdeaths in america
more than 93 000 lives were lost in the
year 2020.
in illinois 3 500 of our neighbors died
of an overdose
a 27 spike from the year before
how did we get to this point who is
responsible for this
there is one clear culprit
the pharmaceutical industry
for years opioid manufacturers
deliberately lied about the risks of
their drugs deliberately
these companies have claimed their
painkillers should be prescribed for
common aches and pains
they even downplayed their addictive
nature
even though their research showed that
it was a very real danger
these companies then shipped mountains
of these pills to every corner of
america
they aggressively promoted them to
doctors with the backing of dark money
organizations
this epidemic wasn't created by some
infectious virus
it was created by corporate greed
corporate greed
in the words of richard sackler of
purdue pharma
his company chose to flood our streets
with quote a blizzard of prescriptions
that will bury the competition
it ended up burying the users
as a result
500 000 american families have had to
bury loved ones who died of opioid
overdoses and addictions
since the start of the opioid epidemic
500 000 americans a figure in the same
range
as the six hundred and ten thousand
americans we've lost to covet nineteen
the numbers
are numbing
from 2006 to 2014 drug companies like
purdue pharma
inundated the country with a hundred
billion
pain pills
100 billion
let that soak in that's roughly
roughly 300 opioid pills
for every living american
they flooded communities like the rural
county of hardin
in downstate illinois
they received enough opioids in
harlan and hardin county
for each resident to have a three-month
supply
some counties in west virginia and
kentucky had twice that level of
oversupply one former rep even bragged
quote i don't know how they can even
house this many bottles
another wrote keep them coming
flying out of here it's like people are
addicted to these things oh wait people
are
that level of greed and disregard for
human suffering is an outrage
and the companies responsible must be
held accountable
you may be asking why haven't we done
that already
it's a good question
because not only was the federal drug
enforcement administration aware of this
obscene volume of overproduction
they authorized it
they gave permission
the drug enforcement administration of
the united states federal government is
responsible for determining the amount
of opioid pills allowed to be put on the
market each year they are effectively
the gatekeeper for these drug
manufacturers and for years years they
allowed opioid production quotas to keep
increasing
between 1993 and 2015 production of
oxycodone increased 39 fold
hydrocodone
12 fold
fentanyl 25 fold
in 2016 america's pharmaceutical
industry produced 14 billion opioid
doses in 2016 alone
enough for every adult in america to
have a three-week supply of opioids
think about that authorized by the
federal government requested by the
pharmaceutical industry we
put a quota
that formula asked for
to produce 14 billion opioid pills in a
year
enough for every american to have a
three-week supply
any wonder that we had an opioid
epidemic
i pressed the drug enforcement
administration on this issue years ago
when i learned of this
i asked them how can you approve these
ever increasing quotas
pharma is insatiable
they will ask for as many pills as they
can possibly push into the american
people's families
especially
when dea had data that showed this
overproduction was fueling a deadly
national drug crisis
a couple years ago i worked with my
republican colleague senator john
kennedy of louisiana to start stemming
the tide of addictive drugs we passed a
bipartisan bill that gave the dea the
authority they said they needed
to set common sense production levels
we changed the law so the dea must must
consider abuse overdose deaths and the
public health impact when determining
opioid quotas
our approach worked
partially
over the past five years the dea has
lowered opioid quotas by an average of
60 percent
the dea this federal agency will soon be
proposing its 2022 quotas
and i'm sending a letter urging them to
use their new authority and common sense
to reign in the greed of big pharma
in face of all this
suffering
new legal challenge has been brought to
hold big pharma accountable for death
and despair of the opioid epidemic
thousands of lawsuits from states county
cities victims have been consolidated in
one federal court in cleveland ohio
this movement reminded me of another
breakthrough moment in public health
when our nation came together to hold
big
big tobacco accountable for its
misleading marketing over the decades
we started holding these companies
accountable in 1998
with the master tobacco settlement
agreement
that settlement was estimated to provide
states with 246 billion dollars over 25
years
but despite the pressing need only a
tiny fraction
a meager 8 of that amount was actually
dedicated to to tobacco prevention and
cessation activities
instead
with the permission of congress
tens of billions from that settlement
have gone toward filling gaps in state
budgets
and funding pet projects like roads and
bridges
stadiums
even a tobacco museum
as new opioid settlements are reached we
must learn from the missed opportunity
with tobacco lawsuits we must ensure
that the funds
from forthcoming opioid settlements are
used to fortify health systems so they
can respond to the current opioid crisis
and prevent our next drug epidemic
all of us know what's going on out there
even people who acknowledge their opioid
addiction
and are desperate for treatment
and need help immediately
wait for weeks and months
to enter a drug rehab facility
that's just unacceptable
we need community and residential-based
treatment we need to expand
naloxone access
we need to bolster our behavioral health
workforce
we need to address the childhood trauma
often at the root of addiction
and other public health strategies
mr president one of the things which i
believe is essential as our kids get
back to school
after the pandemic experience
we need more counselors on the scene at
the schools
dealing with these kids in this
transition back into somewhat normal
life
these are critical moments in a child's
formation
and i hope that we can have resources
available to help them
the best way to hold big pharma
accountable is by compelling these
companies to pay the price for fueling
this crisis
and their restitution should be devoted
to helping america heal
last month a bipartisan group of state
attorneys general
announced the framework of a litigation
settlement involving johnson and johnson
and the nation's three largest drug
distributors
the companies would pay a total of 26
billion dollars over 18 years to resolve
the suits in addition to changing their
business practices
the work isn't over yet and i applaud
the state attorneys general for their
extensive work
involving these opioid defendants
legal proceedings continue for several
other key industry stakeholders that
have yet to be held accountable
that includes the sackler family of
purdue and oxycontin infamy
the sacklers are trying to engineer a
legal scheme to escape liability
through the bankruptcy court
that's the family
that started purdue pharma
that was responsible for this opioid
crisis
they think they found a venue now a
bankruptcy court that is going to get
them off the hook or at least make sure
they can protect the money they've made
off of this criminal enterprise
the sacklers are trying to engineer a
legal scheme to escape liability for
their conduct through the bankruptcy
court
avoiding future lawsuits
while paying 4.5 billion dollars
while protecting their vast fortunes
estimated at over 11 billion dollars
that's why senator warren and i recently
teamed up to introduce
the non-debtor release prohibition act
which would prevent the non-consensual
release of liability through bankruptcy
proceedings
translations
the
sacklers should not get a discounted
ticket to ride
into the sunset
protecting their billions of dollars
they need to be held personally
accountable
and the amount that is charged against
them should reflect the gravity
of their conduct
as legal proceedings continue against
other opioid industry defendants we must
demand that the worst corporate actors
are held accountable for their role in
this crisis
far too many families have suffered as a
result of corporate greed and
malfeasance
mr president i have one additional
statement which i ask be placed in the
record i would just like to speak for a
moment or two uh
on that statement without objection
mr president sometimes you have the best
of luck in life and it's
not planned
but neighbors of ours in springfield
illinois tom and bridget lamont
have invited us to join them at their
little house
uh on lake michigan uh up in
leilani peninsula of
the state of michigan
in that uh time we've had great
experiences together and we've come to
known uh now a terrific
little shop called barb's donuts in
north port michigan
after years and years of wonderful
service
and great product
they are giving up the business soon and
i have put in the record a tribute uh to
barb's donuts of north port michigan i
am joined in this tribute by debbie
stabenow and gary peters the senators of
michigan and i asked consent that this
statement be made a part of the record
without objection
thank you mr president i yield the floor
suggest the absence for quorum
court will call the roll miss baldwin
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
uh the republican whip is recognized
thank you mr president mr president
we are i would ask unanimous consent
that the quorum
call be lifted without objection
mr president in the
time that i've been in the in the
congress
which includes six years in the house of
representatives and now
uh in my 17th year in the senate
i have been a part of or witness to
or voted on
numerous spending proposals and
appropriation bills and
tax bills and deficit reduction bills
and debt limit increase bills and
through the years
and i don't think i've ever seen in all
my time
in the congress a spending bill
where uh democrats didn't want to spend
more
and republicans
wanted to spend less and maybe that's
consistent with our overall governing
philosophies
republicans historically believe in
limited but effective government
in personal freedom coupled with
individual responsibility
in economic freedom
in peace through strength
and
those are sort of guiding principles and
so when you get into a debate about
spending and budgets and appropriation
and taxes and all those sorts of things
mr president
uh in all the time i've been here and i
say this uh with respect to the bill
that's we're going to be voting on here
in a few moments
republicans try and spend
more efficiently more effectively
less
because they know that every dollar they
get spent here is coming from an
american taxpayer
and so when the bipartisan legislation
that the senate will vote on here
momentarily was being considered
it started out at about two and a half
trillion dollars that's what president
biden
wanted to spend on infrastructure
and democrats in the congress and the
senate for sure in the house of
representatives but
in the senate here as well
want to spend way more than what
republicans wanted to spend republicans
on the other hand wanted to come up with
a bill that met the needs that the
country has that was robust in
addressing infrastructure concerns out
there but
spent significantly less than what
democrats have proposed
and that's i i say that mr president
simply because it's been my experience
i've observed this as i've said over the
better part of 25 years now here in the
congress at every debate every fight
about spending
taxes and debt
democrats want to spend more
republicans want to spend
less
and again with the recognition that
every one of those dollars that gets
spent here in washington dc is coming
from an american taxpayer somewhere
across this country
and so
as we think about what we're going to do
next
i have to just say
it is staggering to me what we're
talking about
the dimensions the scale
three and a half trillion dollars
in spending
on top of two trillion dollars spanned
earlier this year
much of which uh was had nothing to do
with the chronovirus and much of the
justification for a lot of the spending
at one time at least
was that we had to deal with the
pandemic the coronavirus
but that's not the case now
and we still have ongoing issues there
we need to make sure that we're
investing in vaccines and all the things
that make sure that people in this
country are able to combat and that
we're able to get this pandemic behind
us
but what we're talking about with this
three and a half trillion dollars of the
democrats are intending and that we're
going to vote on later today three and a
half trillion dollars their own estimate
not ours their own estimate a lot of
private estimates out there suggest that
when this is fully implemented
over the full window you're talking
about five to five and a half trillion
dollars you add to that
the two trillion that has already been
spent earlier this year
all put on the debt by the way all
borrowed from our children and
grandchildren
and you are talking about a stunning
staggering
insane
amount of money
and you know i've heard the analogy used
here on the floor and other places by
democrats saying well this is like the
new deal this is a modern new deal for
america
well mr president the new deal
occurred in the middle of a great
depression where unemployment rates were
running as high as 25 percent
the new deal happened at a time when my
dad grew up through the depression i've
heard him tell the stories through the
years
people were suffering they were
struggling enormously
and the government stepped in with some
programs to help address that to get
people back to work
but what we're talking about here mr
president
is double
double
the size of the new deal as a percentage
of our economy
double
at a time when we've got
and the president was crowing about this
the other day
5
5.4 unemployment in this country 900 000
new jobs created in the last in the last
reporting and so if you think about
where the economy is we're coming out of
the pandemic people are
investing again people are getting out
they're spending money and we're seeing
growth get back into the economy we're
seeing jobs created
it's just it is literally
to me the definition of insanity to pour
three and a half by their estimate by a
lot of other estimates five trillion
more dollars
into the economy
to literally give people free everything
this isn't about addressing
the pandemic or helping get people back
to work we have programs that do that we
have unemployment insurance it's been
been in place now for a long time many
of us think
the plus up that the federal government
provided for too long because it's
keeping people from going back to work
but the fact of the matter is
we are talking about a massive expansion
of the federal government
literally to give people pretty much
free everything
now not only does that contradict i
think what this country was all about
which in its inception
was about freedom and liberty
personal freedom economic freedom
individual
responsibility providing people
incentives to achieve and to do well
making sure that we have programs in
place safety nets for those who
who need that help but the idea that at
a time when the economy is growing and
expanding and unemployment is at a
fairly low rate historically
we are creating jobs that the federal
government would think that it needs
in all its wisdom here in washington dc
to infuse
5 trillion
dollars
we already have inflation to highest
rate in 13 years
you think pouring a lot of flooding the
economy with a whole bunch more money
isn't going to exacerbate the inflation
problem we already have
to mention they're talking about paying
for it i don't think it'll all be paid
for i think a lot will go on the debt
and by the way under this budget that's
being proposed today that the democrats
are
on a one
sided partisan
procedure going to vote on
is uh
is the biggest thing that we have seen
certainly in my lifetime
and will dwarf as i said anything that
we've seen
in history
and the debt at the end of all that at
the end of all that 2031 in the 10-year
budget window
will be 45 trillion dollars
45 trillion dollars 130 percent 134 i
should say of our gross domestic product
there was a day when we were worried
about borrowing
up to 100 of gdp
well we've blown past that we've dwarfed
that
this is now
completely out of control completely out
of hand and we're talking about a
massive new amount of spending to expand
government and to the degree that it is
paid for paid for with taxes that are
going to hit individuals they're going
to hit businesses
that are going to hit small businesses
they're going to hit farmers and
ranchers
you go down the list of taxes of tax
increases in this proposal again i mean
i don't know where you stop
and the idea of the suggestion by the
administration that you're not going to
hit people who make less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year is just
absolutely again i think insane i don't
know how you can how you can raise three
and a half trillion dollars in taxes and
not have an economic impact felt by
people on the lower end of the income
scale
i mean think about it
when when taxes go up on businesses what
happens
well people work for businesses
democrats think it's easy we'll just
raise taxes on businesses businesses
aren't paying enough
well where do people in this country
work
they work for businesses that's where
they get their paychecks that's where
they get their benefits
wages go down
when taxes on businesses go up
to a historical fact and if you think
about what also happens when taxes are
put on businesses businesses obviously
they can do a couple of things there
they may
reduce wages or not hire people or
reduce the size of their workforce but
they also pass that on the cost of
higher prices to people out there in the
economy who are paying the price for
that
that's what we are talking about here
it is absolutely
absolutely
stunning really in my time in the
congress
to observe something that is being
compared to historically
the new deal
in a circumstance where the economy is
growing and expanding people should be
going back to work
and at a time when we have already a 30
trillion dollar debt as i i said headed
in 2031 to 45 trillion dollars in debt
and something that literally dwarfs as a
percentage of the economy what was done
at the time of the new deal
the parallel parallel the analogy that's
being used here by my colleagues on the
other side
there is just absolutely no rationale mr
president for doing this
but that's what it calls for three and a
half trillion dollars
according to budget committee analysts
includes 4.2 trillion in spending when
discretionary spending and increased
interest on the debt are included
this bill that bill which was
entirely unpaid for and i'm talking
about the 1.9 trillion bill that was
passed in march
was ostensibly a coveted relief bill but
in reality was more like a list of
payoffs of democrat constituencies
billions and billions of dollars for
schools while keeping teachers unions
happy by omitting any requirement for
actually getting kids back in the
classroom
even though schools had barely touched
the billions in kobe they'd already been
given and by the way
handouts to state with the distribution
formula heavily weighted in favor of
blue states
included
bailout for union pensions loans for
labor unions
and i could go on
and we talk about
the money that's going to be
you know
and and the budget the democrats are
going to are going to force us to vote
on later today the additional spending
that's going to be in there that's on
top of on top of
the trillions that we put out the door
last year
much of which went to state governments
and many of which don't know how to
spend the money they already have
we're talking
trillions mr president much of whit
which went to as i said blue states but
while
that bill
wasted a lot of taxpayer dollars the
problem with that bill pales
in comparison to what is before us today
today democrats are taking the first
step toward a massive and permanent
expansion government that would pay for
on the backs of ordinary americans
and my colleagues as i said on the other
side i will tell you they're just loving
taxes on the
tax hikes on wealthy americans
but that's not the whole story
those corporate tax hikes that democrats
proposing
that tax just isn't going to be paid for
by ceos and the board members of
corporations a huge part of that is
going to fall on american workers in the
form of things like lower salaries and
fewer opportunities
the tax foundation notes that the share
of the corporate tax burden that falls
on labor is and i quote routinely found
to be between 50 percent and 100 percent
with 70 percent or higher the most
likely outcome
by substantially hiking taxes on
corporations democrats will be
substantially increasing the burden
borne by workers
not to mention
reducing our competitiveness in the
global economy by once again giving the
united states one of the highest
corporate tax rates in the developed
world
with our economy still emerging from the
challenges the coronavirus is very
difficult to understand why democrats
would decide
that we should make american businesses
less competitive on the global stage
and that's the impact of just one
of the democrats tax hikes
i haven't talked about the probable
effects of their tax hike on small
businesses
that's right small businesses
or the negative economic effects of
their huge tax increase on investment
and then then there's the democrats new
death tax that's right a new death tax
to add to our already existing death tax
which will reduce inheritances for
middle class americans around the
country
not to mention threatening the very
existence of family farms and ranches
and small businesses mr president from
the way that democrats have been
governor you'd think that voters had
given them a resounding mandate to
permanently expand government and
implement the socialist fantasies of the
far left in fact
we all know this democrats hold a narrow
majority in the house of representatives
where they lost seats
and the senate is equally split between
democrats and republicans
and democrats far left presidential
candidates couldn't make it out of the
democrat primary
that's right
president biden was able to win the
democrat primary and the general
election because he printed and
presented himself accurately or
inaccurately
as a moderate
but despite their lack of a mandate
democrat leaders are apparently more and
more willing to let the far left of the
democrat party run the show which is why
we're standing here today contemplating
a 4.2 trillion dollar spending spree to
permanently expand the size of
government
mr president we don't yet know all the
details of the pre of the democrats
budget busting spending legislation
but what we do know is not encouraging
in addition to taxes that will burden
hard-working americans and hurt our
economy democrats are contemplating a
new welfare benefit with no associated
work requirement
lots and lots of free stuff
like two free years of community college
elements of democrats most extreme
socialist fantasy the green new deal
amnesty
for individuals here in our country
illegally
funding for tens of thousands
yes
tens of thousands
of new irs agents
a tax cut
for blue state millionaires and
billionaires
and more
and by the way on that point mr
president it's really ironic to me to
hear democrats come down here and talk
about republicans wanting to cut tax
taxes for rich people when this proposal
in this legislation
50 percent
50 percent of the tax cut
by doing away with the cap
on deductibility of state and local
taxes
50 of that benefit goes to people making
more than a million dollars a year
so much for
worrying about people on the low income
of the income scale
democrats want to spend taxpayer dollars
to hire hundreds of thousands of young
people for a civilian climate corps
to fight climate change
civilian climate corps
no word yet on whether this is actually
an effective way to address our nation's
climate challenges but that isn't going
to stop democrats from spending billions
of dollars to find out
and mr president i even haven't even
mentioned how all this new government
spending is likely to increase inflation
americans are already facing significant
inflation thanks in part to democrats
earlier flooding of the economy with
government spending now democrats want
to come close to doubling that spending
and i don't even want to think about
what inflation will look like if they
succeed in their spending plans
mr president
thanks to democrats decision to utilize
special senate budget rules for their
tax and spending spree they have the
ability today
to force through this massive spending
package on a totally partisan basis
but my republican colleagues and i
will do everything we can
to protect americans from the
consequences
of democrats reckless reckless
legislation
i hope some of my colleagues on the
other side
on the other side of the aisle
all it takes is one
will intervene before their party's
taxing and spending spree turns an
economic recovery into an economic
disaster
mr president i yield the floor
senator from ohio is recognized
especially start by uh commending my
colleague from south dakota senator
thune
for his explanation of what's before us
next
after the vote that we're about to take
and that will be getting into the budget
resolution leading to a reconciliation
package
and he's absolutely right these taxes
and this high-level spending is not
something that our country can sustain
and i appreciate his outlining the very
specific impacts it would have on the
people we represent
but this morning mr president i'm also
here to talk about how the senate will
do something very good
today prior to getting into the budget
resolution
the senate's about to make history
and we've heard over the years in fact
over the decades about the need for us
to fix our infrastructure every
president modern times has talked about
it
president bush president obama president
trump president biden we've talked about
it a lot here there's a joke around town
that
infrastructure week has come and gone so
many times
that people
are a little cynical when we talk about
it
well today is infrastructure day we're
actually going to see what we've been
talking about which is the senate on a
bipartisan basis saying you know what it
is time to fix our roads and bridges we
can do so in a responsible way not by
raising taxes on the american people by
making important investments in
long-term capital assets that will last
for years
so it's an investment in fixing up our
roads our bridges
our water systems our railroads
our ports our electrical grids our
broadband network in expanding that
and more
we've had a number of procedural votes
to get us to this point and based on
those procedural votes i think it's
clear that we will have the votes today
on a bipartisan basis
to do this important work
the senate will have done its job
and will have achieved a real lasting
bipartisan victory for the people we
represent
the bill called the infrastructure
investment and jobs act
will improve the lives of all americans
by making these long overdue investments
548 billion dollars over the next five
years in new spending to repair upgrade
and replace the crumbling infrastructure
all of our constituents rely on every
day
that doesn't mean the money is going to
be spent by the way over the next five
years
it's authorized for that period we spend
over the next five 10 15 maybe 20 years
on projects all over the country
we know we need this investment
the american society of civil engineers
gives our american infrastructure a
grade of c minus
they also project that our economy
stands to lose more than 10 trillion
dollars
in economic growth in gdp by 2039 should
we fail to invest in repairs
there's an international organization
that looks at all the countries in the
world and says who's got the best
infrastructure and the worst and by the
way we're number 13 or 14 in that list
now
so many countries are ahead of us
china spends about four times more than
we do on infrastructure as a percent of
their gdp why because they know that'll
make their economy more efficient and
they want to beat us
in the economic
fight that we have globally we want to
win
that's one reason this is so important
the american people by the way
understand the need for this investment
in two of the more recent polls from
cnbc and cbs news
87 of the american people back
bipartisan efforts to fix our roads our
bridges our water systems
we know that this targeted long-term
investment in core infrastructure is
good for the economy building out hard
assets makes us more competitive in the
global economy we'll create hundreds of
thousands of good jobs for builders
plumbers electrical engineers coders
and so many other fields
economists including douglas holdseeken
of the american action forum and michael
strain of the conservative american
enterprise institute have pointed out
that this type of spending
on long-term spending
hard assets
does not further inflation but in fact
is counter inflationary
to me not only does this investment make
sense
but importantly what we're doing here
today also demonstrates to the american
people that we can get our act together
on a bipartisan basis and get something
done
we do big things on a bipartisan basis
if we put our minds to it
again after years even decades of
talking about the need to do this we're
finally getting it done
is exactly the bill i would have drafted
no it's not exactly the bill any senator
in this chamber would have drafted
because it represents a true bipartisan
effort
each side made concessions to find that
common ground
i want to take this opportunity
to briefly thank my colleagues who've
gotten us to this point
we spent a lot of long nights
and long days working to write this
legislation
and there's been a group of members who
have been particularly committed to it
one is shelley moore capito who's on the
floor right now
the work she did with
president biden early on laid the
foundation for this she's also the
ranking member of the epw committee that
produced some of the legislation that we
incorporated on the surface
transportation front
but there are so many others
and i'd like to start with my
counterpart the lead negotiator on this
side of the aisle senator kirsten cinema
of arizona
the two of us began meeting more than
four months ago
to have discussions that would then lay
the foundation for our path forward and
it was in the context of president biden
having
proposed a huge package 2.65 trillion
dollars so-called infrastructure package
and we believed we could pull out real
infrastructure from there take the high
taxes out and get something done for the
american people i commend her for her
leadership
for her courage
and for her ability to keep us on track
during some tough times during this
process
from there it truly became a group
effort particularly among five
republicans and five democrats who spent
a lot of long days and nights
negotiating the framework of this
legislation
some of us have worked together before
at the end of the year and putting
together the so-called 908 framework for
the covet 19 bill that passed late last
year it was also bipartisan
to my friends and colleagues senator
susan collins
mitt romney
lisa murkowski bill cassidy
joe manchin
gene shaheen
mark warner and john tester thank you
for your efforts these past few months
i also want to give special thanks to
our colleague kevin kramer who joined
our group late but was instrumental in
finalizing this agreement
i want to thank the white house and
especially steve rochetty and brian
diese luisa terrell for their support of
this effort and their commitment to
trying to work in a bipartisan way to
get it done
i also want to thank
senator tom carper who just joined us in
the room along with senator capito he
was the epw chair she was the ranking
member that laid much of the foundation
for this legislation particularly with
regards to our roads and our bridges
i want to thank my other colleagues in
the so-called g22
who helped in the 22 different working
groups that were formed to help put this
legislation together
richard burr lindsey graham mike rounds
tom tillis todd young jerry moran chris
coons maggie hassan john hickenlooper
mark kelly angus king
jackie rosen 11 democrats and 11
republicans
and then to my colleagues who voted with
us repeatedly to advance this bill
toward final passage and helped us to
get to this point by giving us good
input that was incorporated in the
legislation
mike crapo
roy blunt
chuck grassley john hoeven jim risch deb
fischer roger wicker john cornyn dan
sullivan
thank you for your input your
encouragement and your support
i want to give a particular thank you to
my friend and colleague our republican
leader senator mitch mcconnell
i want to thank him for his
encouragement and his support throughout
this process
for sticking his neck out
i know he's probably the only person as
happy as i am in this chamber to see us
move forward with this legislation that
will help us find a long-term solution
to a major bridge the brent spence
bridge that links our home states of
ohio and kentucky
i want to thank the committee staffs
who did so much to lay the groundwork
for this legislation about 73
of the pages in this final 2 700 page
legislation our legislation that either
passed the senate or cleared committees
in the senate of in this congress
and that's
a tribute to the quiet bipartisanship
that goes on at the committee level
every day that allows us to get these
things done
with the requisite knowledge and
expertise
i also want to thank all the nonpartisan
staff here in the united states senate
for their work as well i know that over
the past few weeks especially the
legislative council
has worked closely with my staff and the
staffs of other offices to help
formalize his proposal in the final text
before us today they worked weekends
they worked late nights same with the
joint committee on taxation and the
congressional budget office they've
worked around the clock to get us to
this point
and the staff here on the floor
they have been here just as early as we
have in state just as late as any of us
in fact later
to ensure that this could be possible
i thank them
i also want to thank the more than 100
industry associations unions and trade
groups that came forward
to endorse this infrastructure
investment and jobs act that includes
business groups like the chamber of
commerce the business roundtable the
next association of manufacturers it
also includes labor groups like the
afl-cio building trades council the
international brotherhood of teamsters
the laborers
international union of north america
it also includes supporters from all
levels of government including the
national league of cities the u.s
conference of mayors who endorsed it the
national governors association it
includes more than 30 agricultural
groups including the american farm
bureau these organizations and so many
others like them have been critical
to encouraging members of the senate to
do the right thing
and finally i want to again thank my
staff and the staffs of all the members
who worked for months to get this bill
to the finish line we would not be here
without them there is no question about
that
on a personal staff level i want to
thank kevin smith sarah perry every
pearson ann gordon mike sinacore lydia
dennis adeline ewing conor rabb connor
henson
kaylin sweihart matt lloyd and our
entire comms team
angie youngin
and nate denlo
stephanie mertz and chris mitchell
on my homeland security and governmental
affairs staff i want to thank pam
thiessen amanda neeley sam milopoulos
kara mumford trey hicks liam mckenna
jeff post and emily benavides
again we wouldn't be standing here and
about to have this vote
without them working their hearts out
staying late getting in early and
ensuring that every single part of this
bill has been looked over carefully
to make sure we got it right
everyone involved
in this effort can be proud
of what this body is achieving today
senate's doing its job
it's doing its job by helping the
american people we represent
through an historic investment in our
nation's infrastructure that will serve
the american people for decades to come
i yield the floor
[Music]
mr president
senator from west virginia is recognized
thank you mr president i ask unanimous
consent that i be allowed to speak for
up to 10 minutes followed by senators
carper and schumer for up to 10 minutes
each without objection thank you mr
president
well it's great to be on the floor today
uh i think we have much to celebrate
we have a lot of tired people i think
who have devoted a lot of time and
energy uh to this effort and so after a
long week of amendments it's time to get
this done isn't it senator carper my
chairman on epw we've talked all week
about how the infrastructure investment
and jobs act delivers for the american
people and i'm proud that the foundation
of this bill the foundations of this
bill
is as the senator from ohio just
mentioned is based off of the two very
bipartisan unanimously bipartisan epw
infrastructure bills that we passed in
the spring
this historic investment reflects our
commitment to keeping america safe
improving our global competitiveness and
growing our economy
so i'm going to go through a few of the
highlights because i think they're
important for the american people to
know exactly what this bill does it
provides
305 points excuse me 303.5
billion dollars over five years for
federal highway programs a 35
increase from the last bill
there is a new two billion dollar rural
surface transportation grant that will
dedicate resources to the appalachian
development highway system that runs
through many of our states and other
critical projects across rural america
combined
the overall package includes 40 billion
dollars in dedicated resources for
bridges the single largest investment in
bridge infrastructure since the
construction of the interstate system
i'm from a small state i got a lot of
bridges i got a lot of bridges and
unfortunately a lot of them are not in
the best condition this will be a
monumental
uh improvement in what i see every day
in my state the bill authorizes 35
billion for water projects across the
country with a focus on upgrading aging
infrastructure this is the bill that we
passed out of our epw committee
it invests in innovative technologies
and provides assistance to rural and
low-income communities to help them keep
their water safe and clean
this package represents the largest
investment in clean drinking water in
our nation's history
that's something that i think we can all
be proud of there's funding for
broadband
essential to this
21st century economy education tourism
healthcare all the things we've realized
that broadband brings us
and how important it is for each family
and each business to have it ports
airports locks and dams funding for the
corps of engineers will improve our
water resource infrastructure
facilitating the movement of goods
and mitigating flood risks
reauthorization of the aml program will
provide billions of dollars to clean up
abandoned mine sites
it's important in our state
pennsylvania's got a lot of them too
we're fighting against climate change
and we're cleaning up our environment
this legislation doesn't just invest in
our infrastructure but it will quickly
allow it will allow projects to move
more quickly
far too often
infrastructure projects are delayed
because of the expensive and arduous
environmental review and permitting
process
an environmental impact statement under
the nepa act for highway projects takes
an average of seven years think about
how long that is and how much more money
that costs the highway bill unanimously
approved by our epw committee includes
numerous project delivery provisions to
provide a more efficient
predictable process
notably it codifies one federal decision
one federal decision for highway
projects would establish a two-year goal
for completing environmental reviews
this isn't skirting the environmental
process this isn't making sure this
isn't running rough shot over it this is
putting a time clock on it let's move it
require predictable schedules
coordinated by agencies and requires a
single environmental document with
concurrent reviews providing
accountability and transparency
the epw bill that we passed makes other
common sense reforms like allowing
states to be reimbursed for early
utility relocation necessary for a
project while the process is ongoing
additional provisions in the broader
legislation will extend the fast 41
permitting reforms that senator
portman is very very instrumental in to
help us build other types of
infrastructure more efficiently the
reforms and investments this bill makes
aren't just for now but for the next
generation
we've had a very lengthy and robust
debate on the senate floor
i would like to thank senators portman
and cinema
senator collins who's on the floor
senator senator portman
senator cinema senator all of the group
of 20 if i start naming them i'm going
to leave somebody out
but
particularly senators portman and cinema
picked up the ball where i left it uh
you know i'd like to think i got it to
the five yard line not maybe not so
quite but uh i i got the ball rolling
and i got it moving in the right
direction and then they they they did
the tough sledding ahead and i thank
them for that
i would also like to thank my
counterpart
chairman carper he has been great in
managing to manage this bill on the
floor but also to keep the guard rails
on that we established to make sure that
the group the bipartisan group was
following along with the committee had
unanimously passed and how we felt would
be the most effective way to invest in
our infrastructures for the future
i would like to thank my entire epw
committee team
uh starting with my staff director adam
who's been with me for many many years
what you don't know and what i know is
that adam was back in the back with mary
francis
and they were the traffic cops through
the whole amendment process
work in the committees the different
five committees republican democrat
leadership leadership
all of the different individual members
so
i'm i'm gonna give adam one day off and
then i think he'll be right back at it
but i can't he is really irreplaceable
to to our committee but also to this
whole process and also in the in the in
this um chamber with us today lauren
baker and murphy barrett and many many
hours of just incredible depth of
knowledge in this area we couldn't have
done it without you but i'm going to
name the rest of my staff who's not here
with us libby callaway georgiana
clements who will be i announced to
still not have her baby i announced last
time i mentioned her she's she's still
she's still waiting marley collier
travis cohn
uh
sarah delavan
will dixon elizabeth warner max hyman
tyler jenkins jess kramer jake kennedy
matt loops kayla mcmurray taylor
meredith jacob mitchell kelly moore
catherine smith travis boyles and ann
andy zach for their tireless efforts
that have helped advance our committee's
infrastructure legislation on my
personal team i'd like to thank my chief
of staff joel brubacher and also jt
jazerski for their leadership
i really want to thank
senator carper's epw staff
especially mary frances repco who's on
the floor with the senator today but
also rebecca higgins john kane greg
dodson laura gillum jordan baugh heather
dan mackie mcintosh annie demata kenneth
martin and tyler hoffman raritan for
their dedication to this process as well
i will say under mary francis's
leadership and
adam's leadership on my committee i
think they have demonstrated to many
committees and certainly to us as the
chairman and ranking member that you can
have conversations communications and
you can work things out you can work
things out if you just stick with it so
thank you both very very much
uh it's time to bring this bill home and
do the work the american people expect
us to do which to find bipartisan
consensus-driven solutions to our
nation's pressing challenges and this is
a pressing challenge again i urge a vote
yes on this historic bipartisan bill
that will improve our core
infrastructure if we pass this important
legislation
i hope that the house will move swiftly
and as a former member of the house as
we all are the house can move swiftly
when they need to and get this bill to
the president's desk quickly mr
president i yield the floor
mr president
senator from delaware is recognized mr
president i have uh three requests
for committees to meet
today during today's session of the
senate they have the approval of the
majority and minority leaders
mr president uh
sir cavanaugh has been very gracious in
her thanks and and praise and uh
it's now her turn to be on the receiving
end
we uh we've all heard of the the gang of
20 or the gang of 22 the group of 20-22
before there was a gang or a group of 22
there was a gang of one
uh the gentlewoman from
from west virginia my native state
and uh
she
joined in with the president and the
president's uh team
to really get the ball rolling
and sort of took the handoff from what
we had done
working with the administration meeting
with the administration meeting with the
president
but uh when president after that meeting
they decided to engage they decide to
engage with you
and uh eventually and then and then you
you use the football analogy here and i
you might not have gotten the ball into
the
end zone but you certainly got into the
red zone
and we are grateful for for all of your
all your work and you're really you're
good humor and good you're even when
things were we're tough i'm sit right
here down my left is uh mary frances
repco staff director of our epw
committee on democratic side she's
joined today i think on the floor by
john kane by mackey by tyler hoffman
and we have adam over here sitting next
to the ranking member adam i'm not going
to go through a gun before through the
the names of of of your staff but i'll
just say you're all back there and we
are grateful for the great uh support
and work that you've done each one of
you
i i would be remiss if i didn't think uh
you don't get to be uh floor managers
without uh somebody in the leadership
saying well we'd like for you to be
floor managers so senator schumer and
senator mcconnell thank you for putting
your confidence and trust in uh senator
capito and me to the floor staff the
folks who work for the leaders uh thank
you very much
uh from uh to keep us on the uh straight
and and level and heading in the the
right uh direction rob portman's still
here on on the floor i don't see a
kirsten cinema rob is here and rob
succeeds that senator portman succeeds
george vonovich uh dear friend as uh
governor we are governors together and
uh senators together and i i miss george
every day but you have more than filled
his issues my friend and we salute you
for for your leadership and kirsten
senators kirsten's relatively new here
but she has
she has
really
really impressed a lot of people taking
the poll by the horns and the fatigue
never gave up just wouldn't give up and
and then because of her efforts and the
partnership she has with senator
department we are here to to uh to today
i i quoted a couple of times during the
debate uh the words of winston churchill
was in churchill when he was thrown out
of office at the end of world war ii was
asking he left 10 downing street is this
the end he replied famously
this is not the end this is not the
beginning the end this is the end of the
beginning the end of the beginning and
so it is here with with us to today
we are nearing the the end of a debate
in the final vote on the infrastructure
investment and jobs act of 2021
and before we take a vote on the
adoption of this measure i just want to
take a moment to reflect uh briefly on
how this bipartisan infrastructure bill
came to be senator capital capital has
already referred to this but i i want to
reinforce it
in february of this year
at my encouragement
president
biden invited the center capital senator
cardin sir inhofe and me all senior
members of the environment and public
works committee to the white house to
discuss the need to make bold investment
in our nation's crumbling infrastructure
he asked us the environment and public
works committee to lead the effort to
address that need to get to work in our
committee by crafting and reporting to
the full senate to this body
service transportation legislation roads
highways bridges as well as drinking
water and water sanitation
infrastructure
climate change legislation by springtime
that was a request
in the weeks that followed working
together with all 22 members 20 members
rowdy of the environment republicans
committee that's exactly what we did 10
democrats 10 republicans working
together in may we reported out of our
committee a five-year transportation
bill with a unanimous bipartisan vote
20 to zero by more than a third
we increased
by more than a third we increase
investments in our roads our highways
our bridges with an historic climate
title to help address the most serious
channel challenge facing our planet and
that is a threat of global warming
that transportation bill is at the core
of the legislation we consider today
along with the drinking water and
wastewater infrastructure act
legislation was also reported
unanimously out of the committee of
environmental public works earlier this
year and passed by the full senate right
here earlier this year by an 89 to two
vote
that bill targets the most impoverished
communities across america to help them
meet their drinking and wastewater
treatment needs
i'm proud we're proud of the work that
our committee has done made partnership
made possible by the partnership that
that that we in enjoy
i think of the work that we did uh
mr president
i think is like laying the foundation
clean drinking water
wastewater sanitation roads highways
bridges climate really the foundation on
which this package was that was built
and we try to provide an example to the
rest of the the senate the other
committees of jurisdiction and i'd like
to think that maybe maybe we did that
uh leadership uh is is all about uh
leading
and the president uh sought and
encouraged us to try to lead early this
year and i think we've uh we've met that
that request and then some i want to
thank him
uh he didn't give up either
and he's been
in
negotiating with senator capital
negotiating with the team of the gang of
22 never gave up a lot of people said
this is a fool's errand he never gave up
and i'm proud of him and the leadership
that he's provided
available for us uh this before this
body today builds on the strong
bipartisan work of our committee
environment and public works as well as
a good work done by our colleagues and
other committees
commerce committee energy and natural
resources committees uh among them
my appreciation to all who work so
tirelessly on this herculean undertaking
now
let me be clear
um this legislation isn't perfect it's
been said before you'll hear that again
i've never written a bill that was
perfect and it's certainly even though
we've had a fair hand in writing a lot
of it it's not perfect and
despite uh making real progress it
doesn't go as far as we'd like to go in
advancing equity
the way we treat other people golden
rule to other people the way we want to
be treated and tackling the existential
crisis crisis of our time
that is climate change there's much more
work to do on these issues issues that
in my mind i have a more a lot we have a
moral obligation to to address so rest
assured i'll be joining my colleagues in
fighting for progress on these fronts in
the days and weeks ahead
but let's uh not make the uh perfect the
enemy of the good
and make no mistake the bill before us
does a whole lot of good
it's the largest long-term investment in
the nation's infrastructure in almost a
century almost a century
the largest federal investment in
history when it comes to public transit
clean energy transmission
climate resiliency
clean drinking water and wastewater
infrastructure on this day the american
people are looking for us to strengthen
our economy and support our communities
and build for our future
on this day we have a president
dedicated to moving past partisan
divides and meeting the moment for our
nation and on this day leaders in this
body from across the political spectrum
we've come together and shared their
purpose common cause and commitment to
remain you name it
there's a lot of troubled water
in our country
troubled water
and uh i like to think of
this legislation
crafted together across the aisle
bipartisan with the administration uh we
created a bridge over troubled waters
think about that approach over troubled
waters and uh right at a time when we
really needed one and we could use a few
more as as we go along
sometimes when i travel people ask me
say what do you do what do you do anyway
i don't know what i do and on the
airplane or whatever and i say i help
people
and they say how do you help them i
think the best way we can help people to
help them
help them find a job
have a job and they can support
themselves and their families we can
help make sure that they have clean
water to drink
and help make sure they have clean air
to to breathe
that's uh those are ways that we're
helping people with this legislation
bedtime big time and we'll be doing it
for a long time colleagues on this day
we can vote to make a down payment and a
brighter future for our country
i want to join and ask you to join me in
seizing the day and voting to advance
this legislation
uh together
on this day
let us seize the day
carpe diem carpe diem are you aware
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mr president the majority leader is
recognized and first let me before i
begin thank uh senators carper and
capito for managing this bill and doing
it in
such a fine way and their staffs as well
now mr president
it's been a long and winding road
but we have persisted
and now we have arrived
there were many logs in our path
detours along the way
but the american people will now see the
most robust injection of funds into
infrastructure in decades
in a few moments
the senate will pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
dedicating over a trillion dollars to
strengthen every major category of our
country's physical infrastructure
it's been a long time in coming
our economy is number one in the world
but infrastructure ranks number 13.
you'll find better roads bridges
airports
broadband
in the united arab emirates than in the
united states
of america
today
the senate takes a decade's overdue step
to revitalize america's infrastructure
and give our workers our businesses our
economy
the tools to succeed
in the 21st century
the bill
the bill will make large and significant
differences in both productivity and job
creation in america for decades to come
to my colleagues
particularly the group of 10
then 11
then 22
who work so hard in a bipartisan way
congratulations congratulations on a job
well done
thank you to our committee chairs and
ranking members
whose expertise was required at several
stages
and to the staff
who sacrificed weekends family
gatherings and most often sleep in order
to finish this bill
thank you
can we have order mr president
thank you
thank you to president biden
and his team at the white house
president biden has been in office for
only seven months
and already the senate is about to pass
the first major infrastructure package
in over a decade on a bipartisan basis
with his complete and total involvement
throughout the process
i have tried to prod the negotiators
along when they've needed it and given
them space when they've asked for it
at times it took a deadline to kick
negotiations into high gear
other times it required a few extra days
to allow compromise to jail
but when the senate is run with an open
hand
rather than a closed fist
senators can accomplish big things
so despite this long road we've taken
we have finally finally
reached the finish line
of course
we democrats believe we need to do much
more
the bipartisan infrastructure bill is a
very significant bill
but our country has other
very significant
very important challenges
working families need help
small businesses need a leg up
climate change threatens the future of
our planet
our tax code needs to be straightened
out
other parts of our infrastructure not
addressed in this bipartisan bill still
need focus attention and help
so to my colleagues who are concerned
that this does not do enough on climate
for families and making corporations and
the rich pay their fair share
we are moving on to a second track
which will make generational
transformation in these areas
once this bill is complete
the senate will immediately turn to the
second track in our two-track strategy
passing a budget resolution
that will unlock historic investments in
american jobs american families in the
flight against trump for climate change
the two-track strategy
is preceding
full steam ahead
at its core
the democratic budget
both parts
is about restoring the middle class in
the 21st century
and giving more americans the
opportunity to get there
too many in the middle class are worried
about their futures the sunny american
optimism has turned into a sourness and
anger a divisiveness in the land
bold transformative action
on both traditional infrastructure
and on helping families middle class
families cope and on climate
will restore that bright sunny optimism
that has been part of this american
psyche
for centuries
at its core what we want to do is this
we want to
thank you mr chairman
at the core what we want to do is this
we want to cut taxes for american
families
we want to create millions of jobs while
tackling the climate crisis
and we want to pay for it by making
corporations in the wealthy
finally pay their fair share
after we pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill this morning
senators should expect to vote to
proceed to the budget resolution
and we will begin the process for
debating amendments shortly thereafter
democrats are prepared to move quickly
and decisively through the amendment
process
so we can finish what we set out to do
before the end of the work period
the longer it takes to finish
the longer the senate will be in session
at the start of july i set two ambitious
goals for this chamber before our august
recess
one was to pass a bipartisan
infrastructure bill to boost our economy
something the senate has not achieved in
many years this is a strong and bold
accomplishment
the second was to pass a budget
resolution
with the kinds of transformative changes
i've mentioned
pundits called it wishful thinking in a
chamber known for unhurried deliberation
well
we are moments away from achieving the
first goal and i'm confident that very
soon the senate will take the first
major step towards achieving our second
goal
the senate is on track
to finish both tracks and deliver an
outstanding result
for the american people
i yield the floor and
no don't yield the floor
i take back the floor
[Music]
under the previous order all post
culture time is expired
the clerk will read the title of the
bill for the third time
calendar number 100 h.r 3684 an act to
authorize funds for federal aid highways
highway safety programs and transit
programs and for other
purposes the question is on the bill as
amended
gays and nays is there a sufficient
second
there appears to be clerk will call the
rule
ms baldwin mr barrasso mr bennett mrs
blackburn mr blumenthal mr blunt mr
booker mr bozeman mr braun
[Music]
mr brown
[Music]
mr burr
just can't well
this is cavito
mr cardin
mr carper
mr casey
mr cassidy
it's collins
[Music]
it's calling
mr coons
mr cornyn
miss cortes masto
mr cotton
mr cramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr daines
miss duckworth
mr
durbin mrs ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
this is jill brown
mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
mr rono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
it's klobuchar
mr
leahy mr lee
mr lujan
mr lumus
mr mansion
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
mrs murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
movement
[Music]
mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters
so mr peters mr portman mr reed
mr rish
mr romney
miss rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer christie
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
miss smith
ms stavenow
mr sullivan
mr chester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tubberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock miss warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
okay
i didn't want to say that out loud
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin bennett blunt
brown burr
cantwell capito
casey
collins coons duckworth durbin feinstein
fisher gillibrand graham
hassan heinrich hickenlooper hirono
kelly king
klobuchar lujan mansion
menendez merkley padilla portman reed
rosen schatz schumer shaheen
smith stabenow tester warnock white
house
wyden
senators voting in the negative
braun
cornin cotton ernst
haggerty holly hyde smith johnson
kennedy lummus
paul
scott of florida
soon tubberville
mr tillis mr tillis aye
mr grassley mr grassley aye
mr lee mr lee no
[Music]
mr peters mr peters i
mr leahy
mr leahy i
mr marshall mr marshall now
miss cortes masto miss cortez masto i
[Music]
with
mr romney mr romney
mr danes mr james
no
mr sullivan mr sullivan aye
mr crapo mr crabo
mr kane mr kane i
miss warren miss warren
i
miss markow's murkowski miss murkowski i
mrs blackburn mrs blackburn no
mr risch mr risch
aye
um
mr cassidy mr cassidy
i
mr booker mr booker i
hey
mr ossoff i
mr kramer mr kramer aye
mrs murray mrs murray
i
[Music]
mr warner mr warner aye
[Music]
mr toomey mr toomey
no
mr lankford mr lankford
no
mr wicker mr wicker
aye
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
aye
mr van hollen mr van hollen
aye mr rubio mr rubio
no
mr boseman mr boseman no
[Music]
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
aye
[Music]
mr moran
mr moran
no
mr cruz mr cruz
[Music]
time
[Music]
so
mr sanders mr sanders i
the cinema miss cinema eye
mr cardin mr cardin
aye
[Music]
so
no
[Music]
so
so
mr hoeven mr hovind i mr markey mr
markey
i
do
mr xiaomi mr shelby
no
[Music]
mr scott mr scott of south carolina no
[Music]
so
mr inhofe mr inhofe
no
[Music]
so
mr barrasso mr barrasso
no
[Music]
good
round
foreign
so
foreign
mr murphy mr murphy
[Music]
[Music]
on this vote the a's are 69 the nays are
30. the bill as amended is passed
madam president
majority leader
the senate will be in order please once
again congratulations to all of those
who worked hard so hard on this very
significant and very important bill
and now we pre
track
so madam president i move to proceed to
calendar number 122.
senate con s conres 14
the concurrent resolution on the budget
and i ask for the yeas and nays
is there a sufficient second
there is there is
the clerk will call the roll miss
baldwin
mr barrasso
mr bennett
[Music]
mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr
blount booker
thanks guys see you later
vice president
i got you thank you luhan can't well
mr boseman
that's so old
mr brown mr burr
miss cantwell
mrs capito
mr carper mr casey
mr cassidy
miss collins mr coons
mr cornyn
miss cortez masto
mr cotton mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz mr danes
miss duckworth
mr durbin
mrs
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mrs gillibrands
mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
yep thank you
[Music]
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss toronto
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith mr inhofe mr johnson
mr kane mr kennedy
mr kelly mr kennedy
mr king
ms klobuchar
mr lankford
yeah yeah
mr leahy mr lee
mr lujan
miss lomas mr manchin mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
[Music]
uh miss murkowski mr murphy mrs murray
mr ossoff mr padilla mr paul mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr risch
mr romney
ms rosen mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders mr sass
mr schatz mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema miss smith
miss stabenow mr sullivan
oh there's more here okay
mr tester
mr thune mr tillis
mr toomey mr tuberville
mr van hollen mr warner mr warnock
okay it's all good you guys know it
we'll figure it out gotcha miss warren
white house
mr wicker
mr wyden mr young
[Music]
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin blumenthal brown cantwell
cardin carper casey coons durbin
heinrich
hickenlooper kane kelly leahy lujan
mansion marky murphy murray
padilla peters rosen
sanders shots cinema stabenow
van hollen warren warren and walden
senators voting
in the negative
here we go
got you both
barrasso braun burr cappucco collins
cotton cramer danes hagerty hyde smith
inhofe kennedy langford lee murkowski
paul
romney rubio sas scott of south carolina
thune toomey tuberville and wicker this
is gillibrand
aye mr reed
i did i mr booker i
mrs shaheen i
mr schumer i
miss cortez masto uh mr cornyn
no
okay
mr hoeven no
mr tester i
mrs blackburn no
[Music]
[Music]
mr portman no
mr graham
mr king i
[Music]
mr crapo no
[Music]
so
mr marshall no miss rono
aye mr cassidy no
mr hawley now
[Music]
mr scott of florida
no
sir shelby no mr menendez i
[Music]
foreign
mr white house eye
miss hass and i
as soon as you do 51 can i have it
51 yep um
and then 31 51 32 51 the next one he has
got a tag and then
this is 3301 do you want do you have one
that's 32.50 one
no
mr boseman no
oh here it is
merkley i
mr warnock i
[Music]
woof
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr moran
no
mr tillis no
mr blunt
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr bennett eye
[Music]
me
three
mr risch no
[Music]
so
mr ossoff
i
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
miss smith i
[Music]
come on
mr grassley no
mrs feinstein hot aye
[Music]
miss duckworth i
[Music]
more come on
this klobuchar eye
miss llamas no
are you okay
i'm sure
[Music]
okay
you